I predict pain tears chilli strips are
not big at all in Australia I'd say we
don't really have the extreme flavors I
think it's gonna be easier than going to
smash it
yeah I was gonna say it's not very hot
and then it goes down and it is quite
hot there I hate chili and that wasn't
even bad that's very mild
it tastes like chili and lemon lollies
or zone yeah like chili and lemon
washing-up chargin tastes like a Dorito
but a style guru oh yeah yeah I like
that
that was good it was too small it's like
well nice ones we just want to fill your
whole mouth with and go crazy wave like
a preemie yeah I can see myself stuffing
big face balls about it to my face no
saucy not much chili flavor no chili
flavor that's like a 99 cent rate I can
talk about yeah I love it
that kind of hurt me that's definitely
spicy that tastes like my mouth after a
night out complicating them whoa that
doesn't hurt the color or something that
should go in your mouth
who knows I don't even think that
coloring is this it's light bill -
nothing like a and rocked in flavor Reds
it's like a bad twisty twisty that lost
its way slight burning the back of my
mouth at the moment how that was one so
I'm not going in for a handful
this looks like a little bit of rolled
up meat that looks like a salami snake
you are chilly you should not put more
on one amazing - you know I think it'd
be great with a beard just like off hot
chili cheese probably the perfect amount
of chili like I've just been punched in
the throat
smoky chili
oh no chili just smoking it's like a
barbecue flavors style but then move now
that heat is coming and again my mouth's
on fire it tastes really baked me yeah
like a cheese and bacon ball but quite
subtle
bunions I've hired about finance
that'd be good this hour yeah look what
I like the texture it was soft and
fluffy as I said nothing hmm it really
is a fungus I think these ones they
certainly look a lot scarier than they
taste I'm supportive of chili flavored
chips I think we need more of them here
I'll show you how some race to kill the
chip yes but we should